bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct sera vite vous retrouvez au
sommaire ce soir comme on la guerre en
ukraine bouleverse l'ordre mondial en
deux semaines l'invasion russe l'a fait
bouger les lignes politiques les états
unis renouent avec des pays comme le
venezuela la russie de mme andrée l'aide
de pékin l'europe entre dans une
nouvelle ère quant à la dissuasion
nucléaire les plus fragile que jamais
l'ukraine la nouvelle guerre froide
c'est notre grand débat ce soir notre
grand témoin est une figure du débat
intellectuel philosophe romancier cela
fait des années qu'ils explorent le
malaise de l'occident depuis la deuxième
guerre mondiale pour lui volodymyr
zelensky le président ukrainien est
comparable à une sorte de nouveau sur
tille nous en parlerons nous lui
demanderons aussi comment fait-on pour
vivre dans un monde en crise perpétuelle
pascal bruckner est avec nous ce soir
enfin nous retrouverons la fast
résidentiel à 26 jours du premier tour
dans le scan ce soir le carnet de
campagne de stéphane blakowski sur le
défilé des candidats sur tf1 hier soir
le regard de la criminologue mariette
darrigrand sur le président emmanuel
macron et son double candidats enfin la
chronique de jean rémi baudot ce soir
sur le rôle de marion maréchal dans la
campagne d'eric zemmour répond devenu
c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'être au
rendez-vous bonsoir pascal bruckner
c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver sur
ce plateau votre regard de philosophe
nous vous nous intéresse sur cette
guerre en ukraine vous avez signé il ya
quelques jours une longue interview dans
le figaro dans lequel vous vous
réjouissez du réveil de l'europe qui
sortirait enfin écrivez-vous de sa
convalescence
grand basculement à la faveur duquel
vous vous voyez beaucoup de choses on y
reviendra comment on vit aussi pour
survivre dans un monde en crise
permanente la paire matrix enfin de
nombreux fronts climatique pandémique et
est maintenant la guerre maintenant un
front militaire on va en parler
longuement tout à l'heure nous va
commencer je le disais dans le sommaire
par cette nouvelle donne géopolitique
qui se dessine avec cette guerre en
ukraine bonsoir dominique moïsi merci
d'être là professeur de relations
internationales au london king's college
de londres conseiller spécial à
l'institut montaigne bonsoir antoine
bond has on a besoin de votre expertise
sur la chine ce soir vous êtes chercheur
à la fondation pour la recherche
stratégique
pékin joue semble-t-il un jeu trouble
dans ce conflit enfin bonsoir général
christophe coma merci beaucoup d'être
parmi nos ancien directeur du
renseignement militaire ancien chef des
opérations spéciales je signale votre
ouvrage chez taillandier soldats de
l'ombre au coeur des forces spéciales
poutine at il raté son entrée en guerre
même si évidemment c'est un carnage pour
les civils ukrainien c'est l'une des
questions qu'on va vous poser ce soir je
vous donne la parole messieurs dans un
instant on commence par un point de
situation sur cette guerre en ukraine où
les frappes russes ont gagné la capitale
kiev ainsi que l'ouest du pays c'est
signé mario becker
au 20e jour de guerre l'offensive russe
s'intensifient à kiev la capitale a été
bombardée à plusieurs reprises ce matin
et déjà les premiers morts ici c'est un
immeuble de 15 étages qui a été touchée
à 4h20 du matin il ya eu un bruit très
fort ma fille a couru vers moi pour voir
si j'étais en vie
j'étais en vie mais nos fenêtres et nos
portes avait disparu
un couvre-feu de 35 heures a été
décrétée par le maire à partir de ce
soir l'avertissement de poutine à
l'europe la progression russell lente
autour de kiev ont raison de la
résistance des militaires ukrainien
alimenté en armes par les occidentaux
voilà pourquoi dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche et des missiles russes sont
détruits la base de yaro vie située à
l'ouest du pays à 20 kilomètres de la
frontière polonaise faisant au moins 35
morts le site n'a pas été choisi au
hasard avant la guerre il abritait un
centre d'entraînement de l'otan et
depuis le déclenchement du conflit il
servait de plateforme de livraison
d'équipements militaires à l'ukraine
cette frappe apparaît donc comme un
avertissement aux occidentaux pour
mettre fin aux livraisons de matériel
pékin prête à intervenir militairement
face aux déconvenues de son armée sur le
terrain un moscou aurait sollicité
l'aide militaire de la chine selon des
médias américains citant des
responsables de l'administration maiden
une information aussitôt réfutée par
pékin récemment les états unis ont
diffusé une série de fausses nouvelles
visant la chine sur la question du cren
avec des intentions malveillantes la
position de la chine a été claire et
cohérente
nous avons toujours joué un rôle
constructif en appelant à la paix et aux
négociations comment l'opinion publique
russe réagit-elle l information est
strictement contrôlée il est interdit de
prononcer le mot guerre ou invasion pour
décrire la situation en ukraine la
propagande a sa propre façon de raconter
cette guerre à moscou comme à saint
pétersbourg la police patrouille et
arrête tout manifestant
scène incroyable lundi soir une
journaliste a fait irruption sur le
plateau devrait mia le journal télévisé
le plus regardé de russie sur la plus
puissante chaîne de télévision pervyi
kanal sur sa pancarte on peut lire non à
la guerre ne croyez pas à la propagande
on vous ment ici quelques heures plus
tôt elle expliqué son geste dans une
vidéo de ces choses près ce que nous
craignions
ou tuera
marine à ostia nico va a été
immédiatement arrêté cet après midi un
tribunal de moscou l'a condamné à une
amende libéré mais elle risque de
nouvelles poursuites
dominique mans il est je vous propose de
partir justement de l'actualité et de
cette journaliste qui a fait preuve d'un
immense courage en brandissant cette
cette pancarte au journal télévisé avec
ce mot proscrit de guerre on sait que
c'est normalement 15 ans de prison si on
l'écrit et on le prononce et la
mansuétude du kremlin fut reprise on
pouvait s'attendre à ce qu'elles soient
jugés et immédiatement incarcéré
une simple amende qu'est-ce qui se passe
à votre avis
il ya deux interprétations
la première c'est que la russie ne veut
pas ouvertement faire de martyrs et
c'est une manière pour poutine de diogo
toute façon c'est un épiphénomène
elles ne représentent rien je ne vais
même pas la sanctionner lourdement la
deuxième interprétation c'est que ils se
réservent le droit de la sanctionner
beaucoup plus plus tard et de manière
plus discrète
donc et on a beaucoup dit que les
ukrainiens gagner la gare de
communication là tout d'un coup vladimir
poutine prend en compte aussi une sorte
de message à l'intention des opinions
publiques mandat laisse que où il ouvre
la boîte de pandore parce que biberonné
à la à la propagande russe quand on voit
ça on se dit attention si ça si ça n'a
pas d'effet ça pourrait donner voilà
d'autres janvier à d'autres opposants
russes
je peux avoir ce que du pascal mais je
ne suis pas sûr du tout que ça va
encourager
les russes à prendre la rue en se disant
de toute façon il se passera rien on dit
que quinze mille personnes ont été
arrêtées et qu'on les a traités sans
ménagement donc je crois que la
visibilité
de cette personne lui a donné une
certaine immunité
ouais temporaire et je pense qu'il ne
faudrait tirer aucune leçon de cet
événement d'accord avec cette analyse
pascal kouchner le kremlin ne veut pas
lui donner trop d'importance oui
peut-être alors est ce que c'est un
signe de faiblesse ou d'intelligence ça
peut être les deux mais je pense que
l'opinion publique russe est anesthésié
et depuis longtemps parce qu'elle n'a
pas accès aux informations on a quand
même pu tynes a réussi à passer ce
gigantesque pays en
un black out complet cadenassé
complètement la tradition paraît
impensable aujourd'hui est donc
effectivement comme dominique je pense
que cette jeune femme qui est admirable
risque de trébucher sur une marche dans
les jours qui viennent sur les vieilles
méthodes staliniennes ou d'avoir une
crise cardiaque en buvant un verre d'eau
tout est possible avec ce type de régime
empoisonné emprisonné bien évidemment
vous diriez que ce qui se passe en
russie aujourd'hui pour parler de la
guerre mais côté russe
quand on revient aux pires heures de
l'urss où peut pas dire qu on en est
encore là c'est totalement totalement
voilà je crois que mes amis russes me
disent ils sont assez âgés on n'a pas
connu ça depuis staline et et je crois
que poutine se revendique d'ailleurs de
l'héritage de staline donc c'est il ya
des dizaines de milliers d'intellectuels
de personnalités pays vert qui ont
quitté le pays déjà alors poutine patine
général gomart c'est ce qu'on pouvait
lire en une de libération avec un long
article notamment qui s'appuyait sur les
informations du new york times est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ça quels
sont vos informations par rapport à une
opération aux cent cinquante mille
hommes déployées dans le pays on avait
vu des manoeuvres mais cette fois ci
deux semaines après ils sont tous dans
le pays plus de perte caisse comptait
rien ne s'est passé comme prévu on peut
le dire comme ça je ne dirais pas que
poutine patine je dirais qu'il prend
peut-être son temps mais si l'on compare
par exemple la prise de bagdad par les
américains en 2003 ils ont mis un mois
pour prendre bagdad or quand on connaît
la puissance de feu américaine on peut
s'étonner aussi à l'époque je ne crois
pas qu'on ait dit que les américains
patiner face à bagdad et face à saddam
hussein je pense que il prend son temps
certains ont comparé ce à une espèce
d'inondations qui avance est telle que
pleuvent leur présenter les cartes je
crois qu'en fait ils avancent grâce son
artillerie il utilise ce que je note
c'est qu'ils utilisent des vieux
matériel pas les matériels les plus
récents il est us peu son aviation parce
que la défense anti aérienne ukrainienne
existe toujours
et il avance grâce à son artillerie en
fait l'armée russe est très puissante
grâce à son artillerie les chats ne
s'est pas tellement les sharks et les
canons des chars c'est du tir tendu il
avance victime ans il tente des percées
qui marche ce qui marche moins bien mais
je ne crois pas qu'il ait l'intention
d'envahir les villes avec ses soldats
parce que ça serait très coûteux en vies
humaines or l'armée russe la population
russe est vieillissante et je crois pas
qu'ils aient intérêt à perdre énormément
sol dans un combat de rue on a vu bon
opéra thouars qui fait penser à la syrie
aux bombardements sur les civils comme à
alep on va regarder la carte on voit
maintenant très clairement tout le sud
est autour de la mer d'azov est quasi
conquis même si on veut pas dire que
toutes ces villes sont tombées mais tout
de même marion paul carson un nicolas
yves également on va parler du nord dans
un instant mais les chiffres bon il ya
beaucoup de chiffres qui circulent mais
quand on regarde ceux du pentagone 2000
à 4000 morts côté russe c'est beaucoup
je me suis toujours un peu de ce que
racontent les américains quand même du
ciel alors ils ont dit un peu la vérité
1 oui non ce qui les arrange mais c'est
vrai que je pense que les russes ont
perdu pas mal de soldats
trop sans doute c'est pour ça qu'en fait
il va avancer prudemment et il n'engage
pas ses soldats il engage sans la
retirer et en fait il veut faire ployer
ou pliées plus tôt
zielinski volodymyr à nice qui grâce en
tapant tentant sur les immeubles je
reconnais et donc en fait la population
vraiment on va dire halte au feu on se
rend
absolument parce que parce que 10 qui
dit couloir humanitaire dit qu'en fait
on évacue la population des restes en
face des gens les gens qui est en face
sur des combattants ou considérés comme
tels dont vous quelqu'un on va jouer
enfin il va taper comme à gross qui
comme on l'a vu faire un gros souci
l'armée russe travaille comme armée
soviétique avant elle et ses exploits de
la même chose exploite toujours la même
façon grâce à l'artillerie à nouveau
lundi la nouveauté je le disais c'est ce
qui s'est passé dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche avec des frappes russes qui se
sont dangereusement rapproché de la
frontière polono polonaise au nord de
lviv sur cette base militaire de yako
vivent alors expliquez nous cet
avertissement on fait un très clair
puisque on nous parle de 35 personnes
tuées
pas d'étrangers a priori selon les
ukrainiens c'est quand même une base
militaire de l'otan donc expliquez nous
ce n'est pas une base militaire de
l'otan au sens où c'est par l'otan et
envoyer des soldats pour entraîner et ça
donnait rien
maintenant je pense qu'il n'y a plus de
soldats de l'otan qui s'y trouve et je
pense que c'était un vrai avertissement
et de même qu'il a poutine a averti les
gens qui ravitaille en armes et donc je
pense qui tapera sur les convois qui
apporte de l'armement donc c'est une
manière de dire cesser les transferts
d'armements par la frontière polonaise
absolument sinon c'est de la bpco
belligérance on n'est pas encore dans la
co belligérance dans tous les cas il
tapera certainement sierre du
renseignement fiable sur ces convois qui
apporte de l'armement ou ses moyens qui
a pas de l'amour ça peut être des avions
ou des convois terrestres alors la
france on le sait maintenant un livre
des armes on sait même que s'agit de
missiles anti chars missiles milan
des hommes sur le terrain français
forment les ukrainiens je ne pense pas
qu'il ait forme actuellement d'ukraine
s'il y avait des forces spéciales je
pense pas que nous ne saurions et même
donner ma position mon ancienne position
je le sais pas plus que vous je ne suis
plus en charge donc je ne suis plus
amenés à habiliter en connaître mais de
mon point de vue non il n'y en a plus il
y en a eu c'est certain mais il n'a plus
aujourd'hui à l'heure où l'on parle
parce que qui dit quelqu'un des forces
spéciales c'est un militaire donc ça
reconnaîtrait que la france est présente
en ukraine et donc pour être taxé de co
belligérance avec les avec les
ukrainiens donc si je comprends bien
puis on va parler de la chine dans un
instant avec vous tout le monde admet la
russie d'un point de vue militaire on a
encore son pied qui ont conçu pied c'est
certain
mission à la chine aussi rien aux
miliciens oui mais ça c'est qu'on tienne
c'est pour mettre des combattants face
aux combattants ukrainien des
combattants non slave et donc et qui
s'il meurt c'est moins gênant vis-à-vis
de l'opinion publique russe et en
particulier dans l'opinion publique
russie a fait important ce sont les
mères de soldats russes qui représentent
un poids très important en russie depuis
les premiers morts en afghanistan et
d'ailleurs c'est un peu ce qui a fait
rentrer les j'allais dire les rues 189
parce qu'il y avait trop de soldats
morts en afghanistan c'est ça qui a fait
plier la russie en 81 points qu'il
protège aussi ses propres soldats
on va continuer à discuter mais on y
voit plus clair côté militaire antoine
wydad alors là le new york times cite
plusieurs responsables américains qui
explique très clairement poutine a
demandé de l'aide à 6 jiping aide
militaire aide économique déjà est ce
que cette information est fiable alors
déjà une certaine opacité sur
l'information quand est-ce que l'aide
était demandé est-ce qu'elle était
demandé il ya plusieurs semaines est-ce
qu'elle a été demandé il ya plusieurs
jours il ya une vraie différence est ce
que c'est une aide par rapport à ce
conflit précisément où est-ce que c'est
tout simplement une assistance militaire
plus large qui s'inscrit dans la
coopération militaires sino russe la
russie livre des armes à la chine ça
fait des décennies en tout cas depuis le
début des années 90 la chine le fait
aussi mais dans un volume beaucoup plus
restreint donc à la question de quand
est ce que cette demande aurait
deuxièmement il ya la question du timing
de l'annoncé dans la presse de cette
demande évidemment pas du tout un hasard
puisque l'information a fuité dans
l'ignorance et à une reprise par le
financial times le lendemain avec un peu
plus d'informations la veille d'une
rencontre entre jake sullivan et son
homologue chinois yang g chez eux à rome
pour discuter de nombreuses questions
mais évidemment évidemment parler
l'ukraine est l'objectif des américains
il est évidemment de mettre les chinois
mal à l'aise soit les chinois
reconnaissent qu'il ya potentiellement
une assistance militaire dans ce cas là
ils prennent position l'image de la
chine en europe s'effondrer la chine
apparaît comme un adversaire comme la
russie ou alors la chine estime qu'il
n'y a aucune livraison et qu'il n'y en
aura pas et donc évidemment ça risque de
tendre l'alliance enfin en tout cas le
partenariat pardon entre la chine et la
russie est donc évidemment du point de
vue chinois l'objectif a été de dire
c'est une bonne affaire c'est une
désinformation et aujourd'hui même dans
le quotidien du peuple principal journal
quotidien en chine celui du comité
central du parti il y avait un long
article signé par quelqu'un qu'on
appelle zhongxing ce n'est pas un
prête-nom au hasard c'est le prête-nom
qu'utilise le quotidien pour parler des
questions internationales et l'objectif
c'était d'expliquer que les américains
essayer de faire de la désinformation de
mettre la chine mal à l'aise que
évidemment les chinois ne tomberai pas
dans le piège et que la responsabilité
du conflit ce sont les éléments langage
depuis le début ce sont elle revient en
tout cas aux états unis à l'otan alors
pour l'instant la russie de poutine
enfin poutine lui-même est totalement
isolé d'un point de vue diplomatique
mais quand même le rôle de la chine
dominique moïsi on a vu sa neutralité
officielle lors des différents votes ya
eu de vote au conseil de sécurité
neutralité de façade c'est son allié
tout de même est ce que aujourd'hui
pékin a intérêt ou pas du tout intérêt
d'aider son allié russe
je crois qu'il ya eu d'ambiguïté
délibérée de la chine
lors des jeux olympiques où poutine a
été rencontré jean ping à pékin lors de
l'ouverture de ces jeux il ya eu une
sorte d'alliance
pour toujours entre les despotismes
chinois et russe
tout à fait d'accord sur le fait que la
démocratie était obsolète que l'avenir
leur appartenait et on peut penser que
cette occasion poutine a dit il va
peut-être y avoir des opérations
spéciales en ukraine ne vous formalisez
pas je vous informe
simplement
ça ne s'est pas passé comme poutine le
souhaite elle est dans cette affaire le
temps n'est pas galante sommes plus la
guerre dure plus les chinois sont dans
l'embarras car en réalité je me tourne
vers le spécialiste que vous êtes je
crois que
pourquoi vraiment pour bien comprendre
car n'a pas d'intérêt sauf qu'à rentrer
dans une guerre bloc contre bloc je
crois clair je crois qu'il ya de yahia
il ya trois éléments le premier élément
c'est pourquoi se trouvaient
isolés entre guillemets avec un homme
qui est devenu un paria ce n'est pas du
tout la vision de l'harmonie chinoise
poutine c'est une fausse note et ça
devient de plus en plus une fausse note
la deuxième interprétation c'est que en
réalité c'est pas bon pour l'économie
mondiale plus ça dure plus ça affecte
l'économie mondiale donc ce n'est pas
bon pour l'économie chinoise
donc ce n'est pas bon pour le régime
chinois et pour shi gym pline lui même
et la troisième raison c'est que même
pour les beaux yeux de poutine la chine
ne veut pas se trouver isolées elle même
dans le camp des mauvais des méchants
est elle et elle a une vision beaucoup
plus globale de cela et le vrai problème
en réalité c'est que la chine a toujours
dit qu'elle avait une vision à long
terme qu'elles se situaient dans un
horizon qui n'était pas du tout le nôtre
celui des démocraties
qui eux vont d'élection en élection de
confusion en confusion mais là elle se
trouve confronté à un homme qui est dans
le court terme absolu et dont on ne sait
pas quel sera le prochain mouvement
d'accord avec cette analyse oui encore
une fois la chine n'a aucune raison
d'apporter un soutien explicite à la
russie aujourd'hui n'a aucune forme des
daims ni matériel ni économie parce que
c'est vrai veut dire que depuis
l'invasion sujet ping avait levé des
restrictions sur les importations de blé
oui sauf qu'en réalité cet accord a été
annoncé début février avant la guerre
l'augmentation des importations de
pétrole a été négocié avant la guerre
donc on ne peut pas dire que depuis la
guerre il ya eu des décisions
spécifiques qui permettent de mettre
cela en avant mais le prenne pour la
chine c'est un affaiblissement à long
terme de la russie en réalité la chine
avait besoin de la russie non seulement
parce que les deux pays considèrent que
en matière de sécurité politique la
menace était la même ce sont les régimes
démocratiques occidentaux et au premier
rang desquels les états unis et puis
s'il y a un affaiblissement de la russie
potentiellement un changement de régime
ou une évolution politique en russie
parce qu'il ya un mécontentement parce
que il ya une révolution de palais ce
serait évidemment une catastrophe côté
chinois et puis tu as voulu entendre
poutine a déjà perdu presque un des
points de vue chinois pas trop s'en
approcher locaux il faut attendre et sur
le plan économique c'est fondamental il
y a dans quelques mois le 20ème congrès
du parti communiste l'attention elle est
sur la poursuite du développement
économique avec un énorme problème en
chine ces derniers jours dont personne
ne parle c'est la pandémie en chine qui
a à peu près 4000 ou 5000 cas par jour
alors sur nos standards ce n'est
strictement rien mais la conséquence
d'une stratégie zéro co vide
vous allez vous à les isoler des villes
comme sean john le coeur des startups en
chine entre guillemets des régions comme
le jilin des provinces entières et ça ça
va avoir un impact économique
considérable sur l'économie en 2022
beaucoup plus peut-être qu'en 2020 on va
essayer de dessiner le reste on n'a pas
parlé des états unis va parler de
l'europe tout à l'heure mais pascal
bruckner vous écrivez les états unis
dans ce papier du figaro sont usés par
trop de guerres perdues joe biden vous
fait penser à un roosevelt malades au
milieu de ça il a quand même décidé d'un
embargo un job hayden sur le le gaz et
le pétrole russe vous avez l'impression
d'une faiblesse côté côté atlantique
côté états unis ben le sentiment général
qu'ont à dans cette guerre c'est que
aussi bien l'europe que les états unis
après avoir reçu un premier coup a lieu
un premier répercute se sont repris
l'europe évidemment de façon
spectaculaire avec avec macron et tous
les dirigeants et l'allemagne surtout et
les etats-unis alors bye données vieux
et fatigué c'est vrai lit est vrai qu'il
est bègue donc il parle à toute vitesse
on repart la moitié de ces mots mais il
est bien entouré et son conseiller à la
sécurité est assez efficace donc je
pense que des états unis après avoir
après avoir été très divisés les
républicains au tour de trump était
plutôt pro poutine parce qu'ils aiment
bien les hommes forts maintenant
les deux camps sont réunies contre
contre lui parce que les états unis
n'avaient pas eu tort de dire d'entrée
de jeu wii n'attaquera pas oui
n'interviendra pas est-ce que c'est pas
donné un joueur de poker toutes ses
cartes oui oui bien sûr c'était une
erreur
ils se sont rattrapés depuis c'est des
erreurs qui ne sont pas irrémédiables
donc mais ce qui est visible aussi c'est
que l'europe constituer une se
constituer en bloc de défense mais ça
prend à peu près une génération pour
faire une armée donc nous avons encore
besoin des états unis c'est le même
problème depuis 1945
l'otan finalement se réveille ça tout le
monde l'a constaté ça reste ça reste l'
alliance des démocraties
qui est efficace et il faut que ça le
reste l'alliance militaire forte mais je
pense que de remercier monsieur poutine
d'avoir fait réveiller l'europe est ce
que l'europe et a vite dans son réveil
ou plus doucement je l'ignorent mais
c'est vrai que jusqu'à présent le soldat
européen était le soldat français les
autres armées intervenant peu ou pas et
les seuls à dire être capable de faire
une guerre aujourd'hui c'était encore la
france même si les moyens sont
insuffisants et je ne prendrai pas la
place du chef major des armées qui le
dit bien mieux points mais l'otan reste
une structure qui protège l'europe à
n'en pas douter je pense que samedi
l'armée européenne et l'otan oui je dis
ça mais on peut si je veux être un peu
disruptif je dirais c'est sans les
etats-unis et peut-être la turquie
change tout mais
en fait elles existent et les structures
de commandement le plus difficile à
créer en fait ce sont des structures de
commandement
parce que il faut communiquer entre les
entre les différentes unités ce qui est
très difficile dans une coalition c'est
de faire travailler coalition c'est ce
que disait joffre à propos de napoléon
je respecte - napoléon depuis j'ai
demandé moi-même une coalition parce que
se battre une coalition est plus simple
que contre un seul état avec un
commandement centralisé expliquez-nous
franchement on a bien compris que pour
l'instant l'otan n'intervenait pas parce
que l'ukraine n'est pas dans l'otan
est-ce que c'est pas tout simplement
parce que cette fois ci à une menace
nucléaire qu'il faut prendre au sérieux
est-ce que c'est pas ça la vraie raison
qui fait que
malgré tout ces sanctions on est très
attentiste pour les grandes démocraties
qui ont désarmé au tour et c'est ça la
vraie raison est ce que est ce que
l'argument juridique il ya d'autres pays
qui n'étaient pas membres de l'otan qui
ont bénéficié d'une aide extérieure si
bien pour ça que certains pays veulent
s'équiper de l'armé nucléaire je pense à
l'iran je pense à la corée du nord c'est
pour éviter effectivement qu'un jour une
coalition de pays décident de s'en
prendre à ce pays à prendre aujourd'hui
vous qui connaissez l'arsenal russe la
russie est le premier roman avec
l'arsenal américain nous avons petit
arsenal suffisant pour faire très mal ce
pays qui nous attaquerait
ça marche si vous voulez énormément
tenue critiques dont on sort d'une d'une
aire de 30 ans d'après guerre froide je
pense pas que vous l'utilisez armes
nucléaires sincèrement l'arme nucléaire
tactique ton parle poutine
c'est du 20 à 30 kilos tonnes nagasaki
et hiroshima steady kilotonnes oui c'est
bien plus fort encore que nagasaki et
hiroshima donc ça serait ça ferait très
mal et je ne pense pas qu'ils utilisent
il n'a aucun intérêt à le faire c'est ce
que disait de gaulle à son homologue
russe de l'époque il disait mais
utiliser là et on sera morts tous les
deux
qu'il a
dominique moïsi est ce qu'on peut
essayer de comprendre dans quel monde on
est en train de basculer on a
l'impression voilà que c'est une forme
de nouvelle guerre froide qu'on entre
très clairement bloc contre bloc même si
on voit que la chine reste en dehors
pour le moment c'est la fin de
l'innocence
l'expression nouvelle guerre froide et
faussement rassurante car en réalité
nous sommes dans une guerre chaude c'est
la première guerre chaude si hâtive au
coeur de l'europe bon il ya eu les
claquements des balkans dans les années
90 qui a fait plus de cent mille morts
et on ne peut pas la négliger bien
évidemment est-ce que mène désormais
pour longtemps l'ennemi numéro 1 pour
les démocraties occidentales
il est le facteur de nuisance numéro un
l'ennemi numéro un où l'adversaire
numéro un il faut être plus juste ça
reste la chine c'est ça le problème
majeur donc on est dans un moment où
l'histoire du monde ne s'est pas
seulement accéléré mais elle a basculé
et elle a basculé dans quelque chose qui
nous rappellent effectivement la
deuxième guerre mondiale par les images
et ce putin joue là dessus en fait il ya
chez lui cette idée mais vous savez vous
me décrivez comme fou mais faites
attention je peux l'être et et je crois
mais le gain d'une retour de raidô tu
vis à vis c'est quelque chose de
possible ou pas
bleu entendons nous
qu'est ce qu'a fait poutine il a
cristallisé
l'identité ukrainienne les ukrainiens ne
savait pas très bien qu'il était
maintenant ils le savent et ils savent
que leur avenir est à l'ouest et qu'il
est chez nous et le compromis il est là
d'ailleurs c'est à dire vous n'entrerez
pas dans le temps mais vous allez entrer
dans l'union européenne avec des
garanties de sécurité et avec une
neutralité qui s'apparentera à celle de
la suisse ou de la finlande c'est à dire
une neutralité armée et et je crois que
l'important pour nous est à la fois de
tenir bon face à poutine c'est une
épreuve de volonté politique une épreuve
de nerfs c'est à dire de dire oui bien
sûr on a peur sans faire la guerre aux
enfers la gare côté on revient
occidentale stopper cette guerre sans
faire la guerre c'est la ligne
d'emmanuel manon il me semble qu'on
revient aux règles
de la dissuasion appliquée lors de la
crise des missiles de cuba en octobre
1962 moi j'ai enseigné ça pendant des
semaines à mes étudiants l'important
c'est de faire en sorte que la prochaine
étape de l' escalade soit la
responsabilité de l'autre et la prise
d'eau d'où bien entendu notre réaction
par rapport aux no fly zones par rapport
à la no fly zone on a raison c'est à
dire la raison pour le moment ce
qui va se passer si demain il y à des
attaques de missiles russes qui tombent
sur des villes polonaises ou des bases
polonaise
nous devrons faire un choix alors pour
terminer dernier tour de table pascal
bruckner antoine blondin et le général
goma comment comment on peut imaginer
une issue possible à ce conflit
comment arrêter vladimir poutine est-ce
qu'on peut négocier avec lui est-ce que
déjà zelensky aujourd'hui a dit qu'ils
renonçaient est même prêt à le dire face
à face à y rencontrer vladimir poutine
qu'ils renonçaient à entrer dans l'otan
est-ce que ça peut le faire bouger
évidemment on n'est pas dans sa tête
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais on il
faut négocier évidemment avec poutine
voulu parler d'ailleurs des dialogues de
bach rond et de du chancelier allemand
avec poutine ressemble un peu à ces gens
du gign qui négocie des forces d dans
leur maison et qui vise mais non tout va
bien ne t'inquiète pas ça va ne t'énerve
pas il faut lui parler mais il faut à
regarder un pistolet chargé sur sa tempe
ça c'était évident la vraie question
négocié quand même même s'il est capable
de cette violence et de ses mensonges la
vraie question qui moi ce qui m'inquiète
le plus si si les pays baltes ou la
pologne sont atteints par des missiles
que va faire l'otan est ce que l'otan
est capable de réagir pour une affaire
autrement qu'au réagir baril après les
tristes et d'entraidé le confident d'air
dans des zones très élevé on est ici ma
seule peur c'est que l'otan se couche
mais donc cgg n'attendez plus de jeu
antoine bond à ce qu'elles disent qu'ils
prescrivent un vrai rapport de force
mais sur la question de l'union
européenne je pense que du point de vue
du régime russes et notamment poutine
l'union européenne et peut-être au final
beaucoup plus dangereuse que l'otan
parce qu'elle est le message que peut
envoyer la société ukrainienne qui se
rapproche de l'otan 2 de l'union
européenne pardon c'est que la société
russe avoir le même intérêt de le faire
la société russe peut avoir un intérêt
se démocratise et que c'est possible
pour une société slave pour une société
mais je voulais
c'est la hantise c'est la hantise
notamment de la chine lantiss de la
chine c'est de voir ces régimes
autoritaires se démocratise et or depuis
quelques années la russie était un
exemple parfait puisque la société
devenait en tout cas le régime
deviennent de plus en plus autoritaire
tout comme en chine or si on inversait
cette dynamique ici les sociétés
aujourd'hui autoritaire du fait de leurs
gouvernements se démocratisait ça ce
sera un message extrêmement négatif pour
la chine qui est dans une logique
aujourd'hui de rivalité systémique qui
est de dire la démocratie c'est le
déclin la démocratie ce n'est pas
l'avenir nous notre régime de
gouvernement chinois il est peut-être
autoritaire mais il est plus efficace il
est plus stable et l'objectif c'est donc
de démontrer le contraire et staff comme
art le mot de la fin
il a déjà perdu pour vous encore
poutine a une première erreur c'est
d'attaquer lui crée donc pensé personne
à penser qu'ils le feraient ils
commettraient une véritable erreur
stratégique s'il envoyait des missiles
sur des villes polonaises ou des villes
baltes parce que je pense que l'otan
entrerait en guerre et ne pourrait pas
faire autrement sinon elles seraient
totalement décrédibilisé et je pense que
c'en serait fini de loin notre aide et
des valeurs aux rebelles par la même
occasion bombay merci merci beaucoup
d'avoir commencé c'est le début a tiré
les conséquences géopolitiques de ce
grand basculement de ce conflit en
ukraine merci messieurs vous rester avec
moi pascal bruckner va continuer à
parler d'ailleurs de ce grand
basculement du monde avec ce conflit at
on été trop naïfs ou même trop facile et
pour certains pas de l'un des murs
poutine alors que tout de son projet
destructeur était sous nos yeux et si
l'europe en finissait avec une forme de
haine d'elle-même c'est la question vous
poser dans ce grand papier du figaro et
puis surtout comment vivre dans un monde
devenu tragique on a plein de questions
à vous pouvez comme les skis ce sujet
demarco pommier regarder
si on vous invite ce soir pascal
bruckner c'est parce que vous faites
partie de ces intellectuels engagés nous
avons besoin de vos lumières de
philosophes pour comprendre cette guerre
en ukraine une guerre devenu en quelques
jours seulement le sujet numéro un de la
campagne présidentielle
vous savez ce qu'il joue en ukraine
c'est la démocratie c'est la liberté il
y à 1,5 milliard un agresseur et
d'agresser l'agresseur c'est poutine
donc il est le seul coupable ça ne veut
pas dire qu'il est le seul responsable
pascal bruckner vous êtes romancier
philosophe mais aussi membre de
l'académie concours de vous nous
retenons aussi votre mea culpa sur la
guerre en irak en 2003 vous défendiez
une intervention française pour libérer
le peuple de la dictature alors
aujourd'hui en ukraine comment stopper
la guerre sans faire la guerre dans vos
livres vous dénoncez ce que vous appelez
le masochisme occidental cette faculté
de l'homme blanc à ruminer ses propres
barbarie pour vous il est temps de
mettre fin à l'auto culpabilisation des
européens on peut adorer le rock mais il
faut bien reconnaître qu'elle s'est
construite sur le projet de réfuter son
propre passé donc la seule continuité
historique que nous ayons c'est celle du
remords c'est 7 de repentir nous ne
regardons l'histoire que pour dire que
nous avons été abominable non ne fondent
pas un projet là dessus donc il faut
retrouver une certaine fierté de nous
mêmes une fierté retrouvée aujourd'hui
vous saluer le sursaut des nations
européennes engagées dans un rapport de
force avec l'adie mire poutine des
sanctions fortes une allemagne qui
décide d'augmenter son budget militaire
l'europe qui accueille aussi à bras
ouverts des millions de réfugiés
ukrainien elle était pourtant très
divisés en 2015 quand il fallait ouvrir
les portes aux réfugiés syriens alors
n'y at-il pas deux poids deux mesures
monsieur le philosophe
éclairez nous pourquoi cette guerre nous
touche plus que d'autres la guerre at
elle rendu l'europe plus forte comment
vivre dans un monde en crise perpétuelle
des questions complexes vertigineuse
même voilà auquel vous allez répondre
maintenant pascal bruckner examen alors
il ya déjà la divine surprise pour vous
on en a parlé un petit peu avec avec ce
premier débat c'est celle europe depuis
la main sur route vous dites dans ce
texte ce vieux continent pétri de
culpabilité et de mauvaise conscience
depuis les crimes de la seconde guerre
mondiale parle à nouveau d'une seule
voix en sanctionnant la russie vous
parlait même de petits miracles vous
trouvez vraiment que on en est là c'est
mosson sont forts l'europe est au rendez
vous de l'histoire pour le moment alors
ça peut changer avec la hausse des prix
avec des choses très terre à terre un
des détails matériels le renchérissement
des denrées alimentaires les gens
peuvent se détourner et déjà déjà mme
d'ukraine glisse petit à petit dans
l'attention de l'opinion publique mais
en tout cas oui c'est un miracle et
c'était là c'est la défaite des
déclinistes c'est à dire que depuis
vingt ans nous bassine je ne citerai
personne avec la décadence est finie
n'avons plus qu'à contempler nos propres
ruines et puis tout d'un coup sous
l'effet d'une accumulation d'événements
et de la brutalité de cette agression
sur saône rey a réveillé en sursaut et
surtout du côté allemand alors là c'est
celle là c'est là c'est vraiment une
divine surprise c'est sidérant les
allemands étaient une grosse suisse qui
faisait de l'argent les pères avait fait
la guerre les fils faisait des affaires
pour reprendre le fameux poème de
jacques prévert et tout d'un coup le
chancelier olaf scholz se réveille et
dit nous abandonnons nord stream 2 et
nous allons construire une défense et
quand les allemands font une armée
souvenons nous ils sont pas mauvais
alors oui mais voilà ils sont pas vraies
rudi même qu'avec l'investissement les
2% ce serait la première la première
puissance militaire en europe on est on
n'en est pas là ce petit miracle
écrivez-vous s'incarne dans un petit
saltimbanques juifs dont la famille
ukrainienne dyer a été tué par les nazis
volodymyr zelensky nouveau churchill
écrivez vous expliquez-nous cette
comparaison oui nouveau de chercher
parce que moi j'ai regardé les sketches
de deux l1 ce qui bon c'est assez terre
à terre c'est du burlesque
il joue au piano avec son pénis par
exemple il ya fait un sketch qui fait
rire tout le monde mais avant la guerre
il était crédité de 25 % d'avis
favorables aujourd'hui ses 90 ayez une
métamorphose il ya des gens qui sont
révélées par les événements lui l'a été
il est très courageux et hier encore je
crois il s'est promené dans l'entente
kiev il ya visité des hôpitaux et il a
surtout une vision géopolitique
extrêmement juste c'est-à-dire il a
compris comme le disait tout à l'heure
le notre spécialiste de la chine notre
mandat voilà il a compris que le
sait l'europe qui a gagné dans ce dans
ce combat c'est l'europe c'est la
démocratie le pluralisme et la diversité
des opinions c'est vrai que l'europe est
unie c'est vrai qu'elle sanctionne
lourdement
les russes ont fait un poutine ainsi que
livre d art mais il ya quand même et ça
c ces frappes ont une forme
d'impuissance que nous nous vivons à
regarder comme ça autour le carnage vous
trouvez vraiment que cette guerre nous
oblige mais alors jusqu'où concrètement
nous les européens le problème c'est que
matériellement n'avons pas la
possibilité de faire la guerre par la
france qui est la seule nation qui a
gardé dieu merci grâce à de gaulle une
armée forte et vous qui aviez plaidé
pour l'intervention en 2003 et vous
aviez d'ailleurs fermé à culpa là dessus
sur l'irak aujourd'hui vous êtes
convaincus que ce serait une erreur
d'intervenir militairement
alors oui d'une part sur dira que je
faut frapper quand même que les kurdes
et les chiites qui forment 80 % de la
population sont ravis qu'on les ait
débarrassé de saddam hussein petite
parenthèse mais oui ce serait une erreur
parce que
parce que je pense que ça attise la
haine des du duel d'entraîneurs ça nous
entrer il faut beaucoup de doigté faut
beaucoup d'intelligence il faut à la
fois de la fermeté la diplomatie et je
pense que les dirigeants européens
d'ailleurs ne sont pas dépourvus de ces
de ses qualités mais si vous voulez
l'europe depuis 1945 s'est fondé sur un
un serment plus jamais ça plus jamais de
guerre et elle a commencé à désarmer ses
propres sociétés seule l'amérique pour
des raisons historiques est une société
où la violence reste le le un des
fondements de du pays sauf mais
l'amérique effectivement est fatigué des
guerres la débâcle de kaboul récemment
l'a prouvé et donc nous sommes dans un
entre deux mais si la russie nous
attaquer demain si la russie rva hisser
imaginons berlin ou ou varsovie les
forces en présence serait tout à fait
disproportionnée donc il va falloir du
temps pour reconstruire une europe de la
défense ou pour la construire tout
simplement et dans l'intervalle c'est
l'otan et ce sont les états unis qui
sont l'argument en dernière instance on
a vu certains candidats à la
présidentielle rattrapés par leurs
déclarations sur sur poutine marine le
pen jean-luc mélenchon eric zemmour qui
a même dit qu'il rêvait avant l'invasion
d'un poutine français de quoi souffre
notre pays parce qu'elles peuvent faire
pour qu'on ait été que nos élites
étaient à ce point aveugle et fasciné et
ils sont pas les seuls le nombre de
diplomates ou d'anciens ministres des
affaires étrangères qui ont tissé des
des loges à la force du kremlin pourrait
être inclus dans dans ce nombre je veux
un autre pays souffre de mille mots on
se plaint tout le temps passe et c'est
l'anti américanisme
alors oui
c'est une haine c'est une haine des
américains qui est une vieille passion
d'extrême droite et je ne sais pas si
mélenchon et à gauche pour ma part je
n'ai jamais compris pourquoi on me
mettais à gauche moi je ne mettrai plus
tôt dans le clan des brins rouges ont il
ya toute une tradition française
italienne là dedans mais peu importe
alors il ya la haine des états unis il
ya là la fascination pour l'hyper vérité
de mâle dominant
torse nu et on voit bien chez ce que
zemmour peut adorer chez poutine et et
puis il ya cette idée que finalement nos
sociétés seront compliqués et donc
candia complications il faut trancher
d'un coup et la force tranche elle
tranche ll duel taille elle emprisonne
elle bastonne mais au moins elle décide
et il n'ya pas poutine qui est admiré ya
erdogan aussi qui est notre second
ennemi celui là il ne faut quand même
pas le mettre de côté et il a quand même
le projet de rétablir l'empiré ottoman
dans tout l'est de l'europe au
moyen-orient et au maghreb
ce qui me paraît un tout petit peu
déraisonnable mais il est sans doute
plus tenus par les institutions
démocratiques car la turquie ne
l'oublions pas a été un pays
démocratique au contraire de la russie
qui a raté complètement sa sortie du co2
du communisme je voulais vous soumettre
la question marque au pommier dans son
sujet pourquoi cette guerre là nous
émeut temps nous ébranle le temps vous
avez peut-être vu sur les réseaux
sociaux il ya beaucoup de jeunes
notamment qui disent deux poids deux
mesures l'émotion le traitement
médiatique n'était pas au rendez-vous en
syrie en libye au yémen qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ça alors d'abord
l'émotion était au rendez vous je moment
de la guerre en syrie il ya eu quand
même d'immenses débat mais on a
peut-être déjà oublié parce qu'on a la
mémoire courte mais je pense que la
raison c'est pas comme on dit le racisme
ou l'indifférence aux autres c'est que
la guerre en ukraine réveil de paysage
mental de la seconde guerre mondiale or
pour ma génération pour la vôtre aussi
j'imagine savons tous été élevés dans
l'image de ces villes détruites des
temps qui est des des hordes nazies qui
dévastait l'europe orientale du pays qui
en vaille un autre est impliqué mocratie
voilà et et qui donc qui violent la
démocratie et donc c'est toute
l'histoire de l'europe qui est rayé d'un
attrait par
par par l'invasion de poutine et puis
concernant la syrie c'est vrai qu'il y a
eu aussi le souvenir des attentats 2
de l'année 2015 et les opposants à
bachar el-assad malheureusement pour eux
l'armée syrienne libre était aussi
je dirais contaminés par l'idéologie
islamiste et ça a beaucoup joué dans la
méfiance des opinions publiques donc il
ya eu le geste admirable dans gala
merkel mais en même temps
il ya aussi ce combat contre l'islam
radical dont on ne peut pas faire
l'économie aujourd'hui et ça ça compte
beaucoup dans nos décisions dans nos
émotions
les pandémies le climat est aujourd'hui
la guerre le monde est devenu pour
certains apocalyptique en tout cas pour
le moins incertain comment on fait pour
vivre c'est un philosophe que je
m'adresse dans un monde en paix remarque
reese ampère manière la guerre
perpétuelle les crises permanentes oui
alors déjà il faut il faut relativiser
et perma crise nous sommes pas en
ukraine nous ne sommes pas en syrie nous
ne sommes pas au yémen nous sommes en
france où d'allier douce restent douces
malgré le coc vide malgré la menace
climatique et variés les menaces selon
athènes de duduza du nouveau garde de la
russie mais c'est vrai que pour les
jeunes générations qui ont été élevés
dans la douceur dans les roses dans le
dans le dans les bisounours souvenez
vous quand même qu'après chaque attentat
on allait poser des nounours et des
fleurs sur les lieux des attaques cette
génération là n'a pas de mémoire du
totalitarisme or la génération des
baby-boomers à laquelle j'appartiens on
a été élevé par nos parents par nos
grands parents on a été levée dans la
dans las dans le souvenir de la guerre
on n'a parlé que de ça mais alors qu'est
ce qu'ils doivent dire les les parents
aux enfants qui n'est quand même c'est
un manque de collègues aux jeunes
extrêmement chaotique
on sent bien malgré tout que ça sera
peut-être moins facile qu'avant même si
c'est peut-être un peu un leit motiv de
dire c'était mieux avant comment les
parents que nous sommes assumons cette
responsabilité d'un monde lourd et voilà
et dangereux je pense qu'il faut armer
nos enfants pour pour la guerre à venir
pour les pour les tragédies pour les
drames leur apprendre à hiérarchiser
mais ne pas leur présenter une vision du
monde qui soit une vision purement
sécuritaire où tu seras manta bull ça on
fait ça dans sa sur certains campus
américains où les gens s'enferment entre
eux pour ne pas être agressés par les
influences du monde extérieur il faut
apprendre à nos enfants à s'armer
mentalement psychologiquement
contre le
contre les soubresauts de l'histoire qui
sont non pas d une exception qui nous
arrive mais qu'on était là n'en pendant
pendant plus de vingt sienne a oublié
qu'on était
l'exception pour la norme et voilà que
la tragédie comme on dit reviens donc le
le génie des démocraties c'est justement
de maintenir la paix le plus loin
possible pour éviter les affrontements
guerrier ça c'est ici là c'est ici la
raison pour laquelle contrairement aux
prédictions des déclinistes et de toute
la la la la la panoplie d'aidés du
candidat de l'extrême droite
notre notre déclinisme était en fait une
force cachée et ça c'est le génie des
démocraties il faut le reconnaître nous
sommes plus forts que nos ennemis ils
sont plus faible qu'il ne croit vous
restez avec nous on va peut-être quitter
un peu le tragique quoique tragi-comique
pourrait-on dire on va ouvrir la page
présidentielle de cette émission vous
rester avec moi pascal bruckner à 26
jours du premier tour et oui ça passe
vite tout de suite c'est le scala
[Musique]
mais avant l'e3 il y aller de vos traces
de fatalité au grand remplacement et de
la mole vous propose le rose delmore
d'agir pour le climat l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la prendre
orange ma chronique
à bayeux travailleur le système vous
exclus il ya un vrai problème de pouvoir
d'achat rendre à la france sa grandeur
larissa c'est à prague l'histoire c'est
le vol
et voilà tous les soirs jusqu'au choix
des français trois chroniqueurs
différents pour scanner un fait campagne
ce soir mariette darrigrand bonsoir vous
êtes sémiologue on est ravi de vous
avoir vous allez nous parler du
président et de son double candidat dans
un instant jean rémi baudot bonsoir pour
la politique france info et chroniqueur
dans cette émission est l'ami stéphane
blakowski oms on va ouvrir le bal avec
vous l'oeil de blacko on y va qu'est ce
qui attire attirer votre oeil ce soir
aujourd'hui il ya quand même un truc qui
saute aux yeux c'est que manifestement
les français ont très très envie qu'on
organise un grand débat avec tous les
candidats à la télé donc je vous dis ça
c'est pas juste la marotte des
journalistes ou les adversaires des
rencontres leader qu'ils veulent c'est
des français regardez les chiffres
d'audience il ya cinq ans en 2017 tf1
organisait un débat avec 5 candidats il
ya 9 millions 800 mille personnes qui
vont regarder
aujourd'hui en revanche enfin plutôt
fière en revanche le débat houleux qui
n'existait pas il ya des simplement huit
candidats qui ne changeait pas qu'il
était simplement chacun débiter leurs
programmes 4 million deux cent mille
téléspectateurs donc se dire moitié
moins alors vous m'accorderez qu'un
débat 8 ça peut tourner à la foire
d'empoigné mais ça tombe bien viens
parce que c'est justement ça que veulent
les français on veut de la foire
d'empoigné on veut que le président
descendre dans l'arène on veut qu on
s'interpelle on veut qu'on s'engueule on
veut des répliques mémorables c'est ça
dont les français ont envie et encore
une fois c'est pas mon point du
personnel regardez le débat zemmour
pécresse on n'y a rien compris
cacophonie totale et pourtant 5 millions
700 mille personnes 600 mille personnes
au regard des faits un million de plus
que l'émission sérieuse d'hier soir
sérieuse mais ennuyeuse avec le défilé
les uns après les autres et ça ennuyeux
disons qu'au niveau rebondissement ce
pas non plus hyper pas le pilot ça a
permis de passer un peu en vue les trois
quarts des candidats bon ce qui les
quatre qui étaient absents bien sûr
l'été n'était pas content notamment jean
lassalle qui quand on regarde les
sondages le dernier de l'ifop et voyez
même hauteur que l'idéal gouffre il a
été invité mais j'ai pas lui donc il
n'est pas content mais plus il est
triste il est déçu il est même
démoralisé jean deysel
je ne sais pas si je serai un choeur
kabila ce soir parce que cette élection
n'a plus aucun sens elle ne ressemble
plus à rien c'est l'élection suprême
donne des plus grands pays du monde les
regarde et des restes de malheureux
débat auquel je ne cède pas habité par
plus qu'hier soir voilà jean lassalle
qui n'était qui n'étaient pas là alors
parmi les présents sur le plateau de tf1
hier soir qui s'en est le mieux sorti
écoute ya la main qui manifestement dans
cette campagne vit sa meilleure vie
comme disent mes enfants de produire
c'est vraiment un bon moment c'est
évidemment fabien roussel savait que le
parti communiste réunis deux fois plus
d'électeurs que le parti socialiste donc
forcément il est très bonne humeur donc
même hier soir quand il a fait sa petite
intervention pour parler de la hausse
des carburants n'étais pas en colère il
était de bonne humeur donc un peu
ambiance stand up comique vous allez
voir je alors sans les rires enregistrés
pas ridicule on sent que ce n'est pas le
professionnel on sent qu'il débute au
panama en ce moment alors que les vrais
professionnels de l'humour comme jean
luc mélenchon ça ils savent se met la
salle dans la poche lui il a vraiment
fait rire tout le monde mélenchon on
écoute
ses parts ou sépare la salle était vide
on n'a en rien entendu de plus de 10
millions d'un seul coup tout le monde
rigole et c'est mélenchon qui là encore
alors rapidement les autres candidats
bois pas de surprise si je vous dis que
pécresse a un charisme que mélenchon on
le savait évidemment confirmation macron
le pen s'en sont bien tirés celui qui
ont un peu de mal c'est peut-être
zemmour est ce que le fait des sondages
qui baisse est ce que c'est la fatigue
physique extrêmement fatigant une
campagne en tout cas au moment de
conclure notre beau parleur a trébuché
sur un cru là-dessus son écoute
je ne vous promets très pas que ce que
je peux tenir très difficile de
comprendre ce qu'il a voulu dire ce que
vous prendre mettrait pas uniquement ce
que l'on ne peut pas quand a fait
parvenir quelques jeux simples
contrairement aux autres je ne vous
trahirai jamais pas difficile à dire je
ne vous trahirais un homme politique
trébuché sur ils n'arrivent pas au
moment de conclure à dire je ne trahirai
jamais quand même ça met un petit
malheur est bon en tout cas on réclame
un débat il y en a pas mais jeudi le
président s'exprime en présentant son
programme de la presse pourra peut-être
avoir pris part à ce débat mais
peut-être que voilà toutes les questions
pourront être posées je suis sûr que ça
vous intéresse le le lapsus à marianne2
d'eric zemmour vous aussi vous vous
intéressez à emmanuel macron donc on a
le on a le mât croupe deux pour le prix
d'un c'est ce que nous on est saisi de
ce soir le président et le candidat oui
c'est la première fois que c'est pas la
première fois qu'un président en charge
se représente qui devient candidat mais
d'habitude on a un mot double en à
président candidat ou candidat président
mais là on a carrément une distinction
un dédoublement de la personnalité d'une
certaine façon emmanuel macron et/ou
candidat ou président ça dépend il
alterne il nous parle en tant que tel il
il alterne les deux positions alors je
trouve ça très intéressant parce que ça
passe aussi par des codes couleurs le
président est toujours en noir et le
candidat est souvent en blanc et ça
correspond exactement à l'étymologie
pour voir à l'antenne situation
gémissent blanche sur tour des français
voient de rousset et les vestes noires
quand il est le chef de guerre à
l'elysée et alors le président est
souvent assis d'ailleurs ça veut dire ça
étymologiquement un price et d'airé
c'est à dire celui qui s'assied devant
les autres parce qu'il les représente ou
bien parce qu'il a devant lui par
exemple au bout de la grande table la
dmr poutine ou d'autres chefs d'état
donc il est solennel il a son
préféré s'asseoir rien à vendre et
pécresse a fait le choix elle déambule
et un peu
il se compose d un moment alors ce qui
m'intéresse là dedans c'est de réfléchir
à notre culture politique 1 c'est à dire
qu'on a ce qu'on une théorie très connue
bien sûr pascal bruckner on a parlé déjà
c'est la théorie du double corps du roi
donc le roi il est comme nous il est
mortel mais il est aussi immortel comme
dieu donc il a un double corps il est
mort et il vit alors quand horowitz
quant aux peines kantorowicz voilà la
finlande elle voit la mayonnaise
d'étudiantes oui c'est une théorique
vraiment très intéressante justement par
rapport aux signes contemporain et du
coup notre président né pendant n'est
pas la forte heureusement françois
mitterrand par exemple a déjà commencé
un peu durant son deuxième septennat il
allait un peu dans les larmes après là
on en est pas du tout là avec emmanuel
macron on est plutôt dans une autre
question à mon avis qui rejoint ce que
vous disiez un instant c'est à dire
c'est un peu comme si ils avaient besoin
d'un ennemi intérieur ou d'un autre
intérieur il s'est peut-être fait un
candidat alors qu'il est président pour
discuter pour se disputer pour avoir ce
challenge et faute d'adversaire être
parce que il n'a pas assez d'adversaire
pour parler alors je ne veux pas dire
par là qu'il a un problème de santé
mentale pas du tout débat avec son
double peut-être mais je pense que c'est
plutôt notre démocratie qu'à un petit
problème de santé car évidemment vous
l'avait bien dit tout à l'heure un la
démocratie c'est quand même le débat il
a discuté entre adversaires d'un tout
petit mot pensait que il a tort emmanuel
macron de refuser le débat avec ses
opposants je suis pas dans sa tête mais
en tant que citoyen dans l'instant
l'urgence de la situation fait kid et il
est le commandant en chef et donc il ne
va pas se commettre à
contre sens dans l'art elle descend dans
l'arène mais s'il tarde trop on le lui
reprochant après ce sera une victoire à
la pyrrhus qui va payer pendant quatre
ans donc il wifi fasse très attention
alors on va passer un autre candidat on
va parler d'eric zemmour mais surtout on
va parler de marion maréchal nouvelle
affiche de campagne jean rémi baudot
elle a retenu votre attention cette
semaine une affiche où justement eric
zemmour est aux côtés de marion maréchal
affiches publiées dans le week-end donc
il n'est pas seul ils sont l'un à côté
de l'autre bras levés main dans la main
cette photo elle a été prise il ya dix
jours lors du meeting de toulon où
marion maréchal a donc apporté
officiellement son soutien à eric
zemmour et cette affiche elle ressemble
à un ticket un ticket pas de politique
la promotion d'un ticket ou est
absolument eric zemmour président marion
maréchal bar on sait pas encore trop
quoi c'est d'ailleurs l'une des
questions on y reviendra depuis le début
de la campagne marion maréchal est en
fait la seule avoir eu de tels honneurs
on n'a pas vu des affiches avec eric
zemmour et philippe de villiers ou
nicolas bay s'est d'ailleurs je pense
assez inédit dans une campagne
présidentielle qu'il y ait deux
personnes sur une affiche et donc par
cette affiche jean-rémy eric zemmour met
en scène cette nouvelle addition les cas
il faut dire que médiatiquement ce
ralliement il était annoncé il était
attendu mais il était surtout un peu
passé inaperçu il ya une dizaine de
jours à cause de l'actualité ukrainienne
il a d'ailleurs eu aucun aucun impact
les sondages mais si on regarde bien
cette affiche en fait elle nous parle de
l'avenir de la droite
parmi les éléments qui font que c'est
intéressant pour lui de montrer marion
maréchal c'est que c'est une femme sator
l'idée qu'il serait misogyne c'est une
l'open c'est toujours une toujours bien
apprendre c'est un signe envoyé
évidemment aux arènes et puis il ya ce
message unis pour la france la question
s'est unie jusqu'à quand on ne sait pas
pour l'heure marion maréchal elle ne
fait pas partie de reconquête elle n'a
pas de place dans la campagne on ne sait
pas quel sera son rôle pendant la
présidentielle pour poser dans le
prochain quinquennal pourrait tenter de
faire entendre rapidement peut-être sa
propre musique et d'ailleurs ça a
commencé je sais pas si vous avez
entendu dimanche dernier elle a pris ses
distances avec certaines propositions
sur les prénoms sur la confusion entre
islam et islamistes tout laisse penser
donc marion maréchal va peut-être se
servir d'eric zemmour comme d'un
marchepied pour la suite elle a ses
réseaux à la son expérience elle a des
soutiens notamment dans la presse
identitaire en cas d'échec de zemmour à
la présidentielle elle pourrait donc
tenter de prendre la tête de cette
nouvelle route et puisqu'on parlait d d
d d d habitude tout à l'heure ça va
ramener un lapsus de d'eric zemmour je
ne vois que ce que je crois c'est qu'il
a dit le ski l'a dit l'autre jour dans
un dans un débat télévisé on verra s'ils
voient venir à la menace dans son propre
camp on verra ça effectivement ça pèse
marion maréchal en terme électoral ou
penser ça lui ramène des voix 0 entrer
complètement raté c'était annoncé l
avance que sa tef basculer quelque chose
finalement on s'était vendu quand elle
avait venu au meeting on savait déjà que
j'allais annoncer ça prouve qu'elle joue
le coup d'après elle achète à la baisse
à la une école une école qui marchent
pas qui marque qui vient coup de
subventions elle est là elle a été élue
sans rien donc je vois je vois pas trop
tous ses proches sont déjà c'est chez
moi donc c'est probablement la preuve
qu'il fut la seule à beaucoup je mens
une petite parenthèse je trouve que
zemmour ans avec le temps ressemble de
plus en plus à michel rocard en lit que
c'était mariera tout physiquement ça
michel royo à vous trouver oui oui oui
et il allait et le lapsus de cela me
fait penser à rocard qui bafouille et il
parlait à toute vitesse aussi personnes
comprenait ce qu'il disait et dire je ne
vois que ce que je crois c'est quand
même c'est terrible parce que c'est la
définition même du croyant du fanatique
ou d'idéologues c'est à dire qu'on ne
voit rien si on ne voit que ce qu'on
croit se dire qu'on met dans les
événements
projet dans les événements ses proches
s'approprier le geig donc c'est
inquiétant mais enfin bon voilà c'est un
commentaire non mais c'est intéressant
de citoyens aussi et d'analystes merci à
vous merci pour vos regards merci marié
de l'arrivant vous revenez quand vous
voulez l'oeil de blacko c'est tous les
soirs vous savez j'aurais nouveau dos et
le mardi dans ça vous regarde très belle
soirée documentaire qui continuent
d'ailleurs à disséquer ce conflit en
ukraine avec un film qui revient sur le
conflit plus anciens du donbass donesk
la bataille de l'ukraine trabesse part
et à demain
[Musique]